wie geht es weiter nach corona unser
alltag ist auf den kopf gestellt und die
welle von neuinfektionen ist eine echte
belastung für unser gesundheitssystem
doch wie wird es aussehen wenn dieser
erste große ausbruch überstanden ist
werden wir immun gegen saas kopf 2 und
werden wir das virus irgendwann komplett
ausschalten können pixum science fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und
aktivierte glocke nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
weltweit gibt es immer mehr
ausgangssperren die zahl der infizierten
steigt und auch hier in deutschland ist
unser alltag nicht mehr derselbe
die schulen sind geschlossen viele
arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmerinnen
machen ihren job von zu hause aus und
vor den supermärkten gibt es zum teil
lange schlangen von menschen weil nur
begrenzt viele leute gleichzeitig in die
läden dürfen was in den kommenden wochen
und monaten noch auf uns zukommt lässt
sich noch nicht sagen klar ist nur dass
sich das virus weiter und schneller
ausbreiten wird und es noch viel mehr
infizierte geben wird der infektiologe
jonczy bohr leitet das institut für
medizinische virologie an der
universität gießen und er meint die
frage sei lediglich wie schnell das
passieren wird die aktuellen maßnahmen
sind dazu da die verbreitung des virus
möglichst weit zu verlangsamen der
experte hält das für sehr wichtig um
unser krankenhaus system nicht mit
schwerkranken fällen für die
intensivstationen zu überlasten was die
zahl der opfer verzehnfachen kann
er hält es auch für wahrscheinlich dass
sich diese situation über mehrere monate
hinziehen wird mit etwas glück könnten
die zahlen der neuinfektionen im sommer
sinken und dann könnte man die maßnahmen
stück für stück wieder lockern für eine
gewisse zeit aber aktuell müssen wir die
ausbreitung des virus so gut wie möglich
verzögern doch wie sieht eigentlich
unsere zukunft in der zeit nach dem
ausbruch aus dass corona virus wird
unser gesundheitssystem weiter belasten
gerade krankenhäuser werden vor
herausforderungen stehen wenn weiterhin
viele betroffene intensivmedizinisch
betreut werden müssen geplante ps die
verschoben werden müssen die
unterbringung von unaufschiebbaren op s
und das infektionsrisiko für
medizinisches personal sind probleme
denen wir uns auch in zukunft stellen
müssen der experte befürchtet dass sich
zunehmend auch ärzte und pflegekräfte
infizieren werden und das zum teil
unbemerkt es muss sichergestellt werden
dass das fachpersonal regelmäßig
getestet
wird auch wenn es keine symptome zeigt
dann ist die frage was man mit
infiziertem personal macht und ob es
wenigstens noch in weniger kritischen
bereichen eingesetzt werden kann aber
werden wir nicht irgendwann immun gegen
cupid 19 ja aber leider gibt auch die
immunität die sich nach einer
infizierung bildet nicht gerade viel
hoffnung denn sie schützt nur für einen
zeitraum von vielleicht mehreren jahren
das bedeutet zwar eine herdenimmunität
das virus wird sich nicht mehr so
schnell verbreiten aber wenn sie dann
nach lässt kann das virus trotzdem in
einigen jahren ausgerechnet vermehrt
kinder befallen das liegt daran dass
babys nur mit einer leihe immunität
ihrer mutter zur welt kommen die relativ
flüchtig ist nun nur wenige monate
schutz bietet danach müssen kleinkinder
eine eigene immunität gegen verschiedene
viren bilden man sieht das an fällen wie
lässt sich zum beispiel als ein masern
erkranktes kind deshalb nicht geimpft
war
drei kleine babys in einem wartezimmer
angesteckt hat die drei kinder sind alle
gestorben
kinder sind deshalb anfällig für die
meisten atemwegs wir unglücklicherweise
aber mit recht milden verläufen was auch
sehr beunruhigend ist ist die
vorstellung dass coop 19 in zukunft
gleichzeitig mit der grippe ausbrechen
könnte die folgen für unser
gesundheitssystem wären laut john c dur
schwerwiegend tatsächlich kann man sich
gleichzeitig mit corona viren und
influenza viren infizieren
das corona virus könnte anderen viren
helfen sich im körper auszubreiten
die grippe impfquote sollte also auf
jeden fall so weit wie möglich erhöht
werden aber werden wir denn das virus
nicht nach dem ausbruch wieder los der
infektiologe glaubt nicht dass das virus
wieder komplett verschwinden wird weil
es so viele infizierte gibt und noch
geben wird auch wegen der parallelen zu
anderen coronaviren geht er davon aus
dass wir es nicht schaffen dieses virus
komplett zu eliminieren
das virus ist also in der welt für immer
auf die gesundheitspolitiker und das
gesamte gesundheitssystem kommen schwere
entscheidung zu aber wir werden wege
finden damit umzugehen und schon jetzt
sieht man welche großartigen einsatz die
menschen bringen die unser
gesundheitssystem am laufen halten und
mit wie viel engagement forschende nach
medikamenten und impfstoffen suchen
hoffnung gibt es also auf jeden fall
dass wir uns irgendwann zur begrüßung
werden die hände schütteln und uns
umarmen können aber die welt wird nach
corona eine andere
ein alle videos zu corona gibt es hier
auf dem kanal bei uns könnte video für
video verfolgen wie die pandemie
entstanden ist und schon sehr früh habe
ich hier im gegensatz zu den mainstream
medien darüber berichtet und die
konsequenzen aufgezeigt und die
jeweilige entwicklung kritisch beäugt an
dieser stelle vielen vielen dank für die
unterstützung hier als kanal mitglieder
zahlreiche kommen in diesen tagen hinzu
und honorieren diese berichterstattung
danke man muss kein fan von alternativen
fakten und verschwörungstheorien seien
um frühzeitig auf gefahren aufmerksam zu
machen und mit offenen augen und ohren
durch die welt zu gehen und unabhängigen
journalismus ohne panikmache und ohne
verharmlosung zu gewährleisten ich danke
euch bleibt pixum treu hier geht es zur
playlist also anklicken anschauen und am
besten dafür im riesen dank klick zum
kanal mitglied werden in diesen zeiten
können wir wirklich jede unterstützung
gebrauchen bis dann bleibt dran